Okay, this is getting to be a lot
of stuff about IP addresses,
why do we care so
much about them anyway?
So, all traffic on the Internet is
split up into messages called packets.
And each packet has the addresses of its
source or sender and it's destination or
intended recipient on it.
When you use Ping, you're sending a
steady stream of packets to a particular
destination and hopefully,
you're getting a steady stream back.
So each server or
other host that you want to talk to,
it needs to have a distinct IP address.
Now, that would be fine, but
there aren't enough IP addresses for
all the computers today.
Remember, there's about 4 billion IPv4
addresses available for hosts, and
there's 7 billion people on the planet.
To make it worse, big institutions that
have been on the internet since forever
are using way more than their
fair share of addresses.
And the addresses to people ratio in
the US is actually a lot higher than
the rest of the world, especially
Latin America, Asia, and Africa.
At the end of this lesson I'll tell
you more about how we're fixing
this problem.
But before we get there I have to
confess that I've been lying to you
about something.